[rapping gavel]
- DR. ARMOND, PLEASE RISE.
YOU STAND HERE ACCUSED OF MURDER
IN THE SECOND DEGREE.
HOW DO YOU PLEAD?
- GUILTY...OF LOVING MY WIFE.
- [laughs]
- HMM, WELL,
WE'LL SEE ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THE COURT WILL DECIDE
THAT PROBABLY
YOU'RE GUILTY OF MURDER.
[hawk screeches]
[intense music]
- OPENING ARGUMENTS
WERE AN ABSOLUTE SLAUGHTER
AS FRIENDLY
DEFENSE ATTORNEY RON FUNCHES
COULDN'T COPE WITH THE ONSLAUGHT
FROM HARD-CHARGING PROSECUTOR
RUTH DIAMOND PHILLIPS.
- A LOT CAN HAPPEN
IN TEN SECONDS.
YOU'D BE SURPRISED.
LET ME SURPRISE YOU.
ONE, HE BUSTS INTO THE ROOM.
TWO, "SHUT UP,"
HE PROBABLY SAID.
WHO KNOWS?
THREE, HE TAKES OUT
A LARGE NEEDLE
TO PUT DOWN HORSES
THAT HAVE HURT THEIR FEET
BECAUSE THEY RUN TOO FAST
IN RACES
AND ACTUALLY,
THEY CAN'T EVEN LIVE ANYMORE
AND THEY HAVE TO
PUT THEM DOWN.
HE PUTS THE NEEDLE
INTO HER FOREHEAD,
THROWS HER ACROSS THE ROOM
WITH THE BRUTE STRENGTH
OF A VETERINARIAN.
- WHILE RON FUNCHES
SEEMS TO BE PLAYING A GAME,
THE RULES OF WHICH
WE DO NOT KNOW.
- WOULD A MURDERER
WEAR THAT HILARIOUS APRON?
[snickering]
LOOK AT THAT APRON.
- AS FOR THE WITNESSES,
DETECTIVE SMART'S TESTIMONY
SHOULD'VE BEEN ENOUGH
TO CONVINCE ANYONE.
THE FORENSICS WERE DAZZLING.
- AT THAT POINT,
I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT HIS TORSO WAS RIGHT UP
AGAINST THAT--
THAT HEAVING BOSOM.
- MM.
- I'M SURPRISED HE WAS ABLE TO
GET THE SYRINGE KIND OF PAST...
- PAST JUST HOW THE BREASTS
WOULD PROBABLY
ALMOST STAND AT ATTENTION.
- LIKE, UH...
DOMINIQUE WILKINS
BACK IN THE DAY,
THAT TOMAHAWK SLAM
HE USED TO DO?
- YEAH.
- YEAH, SO PUT LIKE A SYRINGE
RIGHT THROUGH HER FOREHEAD.
- THE HUMAN HIGHLIGHT FILM.
- THAT IS TRUE.
- EVEN HIS OWN SON COULDN'T SAY
HE DIDN'T DO IT.
- YOU'RE NOT COOL AT ALL.
YOU'RE COMPLETELY
THE OPPOSITE OF COOL.
- HE'S THE OPPOSITE OF COOL.
- YUP.
- MIGHT THAT BE...
A MURDERER?
- YEAH.
[courtroom murmuring]
- GO GET 'EM, RUTH.
[intense music]